I want to start out by talking
about real estate as an asset class.
It's actually the biggest and
most important asset class. Uh,
the value of real estate in the United
States today is a of real estate owned by
households directly is about $20 trillion,
which makes it a comparable,
uh,
or maybe a little bit bigger than
that. Then the stock market. Uh,
and so, uh, stocks owned
directly by households are only,
uh, about 6 trillion. So
for a typical household,
the home is the, is the major source
of wealth that they've accumulated.
Uh,
Chris,
other stocks are held by institutions
on their behalf, but, uh,
in terms of direct ownership, homes
are, are the main thing that people own.
MMM.
So, uh, there's also
commercial real estate,
which is smaller than
owner occupied homes, uh,
but we own that indirectly to,
as the people through the stocks that
we own and through the institutions we
participate in. Uh, so
it's very important,
uh, and it has some
important, uh, financial.
Uh,
there's a lot of financial institutions
built around dealing with the
fundamental problems of real estate.
So I wanted to talk first
about institutions, uh,
and then move to what I think
is myself more interesting,
which is the real estate boom. Uh, and,
and the kind of s fluctuations we've
seen in real estate over the years.
So I'm going to start out by talking
about commercial real estate and the kind
of vehicles that, uh, um, uh,
we used to invest in
commercial real estate. Uh,
and then I want to talk about mortgages,
which is the way that we
finance both commercial and, uh,
owner occupied real estate. And then
finally, I want to come to the, uh,
real estate boom that we are recently in.
Uh,
so,
uh,
so let me start by,
the way that the kind of institution
that you probably know relatively little
about
for commercial real estate,
commercial real estate,
that means real estate owned
not by individual households,
but by businesses. Okay. Uh,
and, uh, the, the, uh,
institution I wanted to talk to
you about, first one, it's called
a DPP,
a direct participation
program,
which has been traditionally,
uh,
the single most important form of
holding of commercial real estate.
So when you drive along and you
see all these commercial buildings,
you might wonder who owns
them. Well, sometimes they're
owned by corporations, but,
uh, I think the more important
institution is the DPP,
uh, which is, um, uh, uh,
a,
uh,
a financial vehicle that owns commercial
real estate on behalf of investors.
Uh, and so, uh, the,
uh, most important DPP,
uh,
it's called a limited partnership
or LP.
Uh,
there's a very simple reason why real
estate tends to be held in limited
partnerships rather than corporations.
And that reason is the corporate profits
tax corporations are taxed on their
profits, uh, and, uh,
DPPS are not. Uh, and so you want,
if you are setting up an
organization to hold real estate,
you want to do it if
you can, as a DPP, uh,
because you don't want to
pay those taxes. And so, uh,
whenever possible, uh, uh, a, um,
uh, ownership, uh,
vehicle for commercial real estate
will have the form of a DPP.
Um,
and a limited partner is a ship,
is one kind of DPP, uh, and it has,
it's not a corporation.
So it's a partnership. Uh,
at the simplest kind of partnership would
be if several of you got together and
formed the business. Uh, and in a
normal and a simple partnership,
the partnership would not be taxed
because it's you doing business just as
partners. Uh, and so you are
taxed but not the partnership.
But the problem with partnerships
generally has been that they don't have
limited liability.
A corporation is an entity
that could be sued, uh,
for uh,
or could lose more money than it's worth.
But the value of a corporation can
never fall below zero because to the
investors,
because the investors are not liable
for the mistakes of the corporation.
If you buy stock in a company, the most
you can lose is the money you put up.
So that's called limited liability.
But if you take part in a partnership,
uh, you are individually liable
for the debts of the corporation.
And that's a problem with the partnership
structure because you could join a
partnership, uh, and uh, the partnership
does something awful and loses,
uh, more than you put into it and they
can come after you for those losses.
There is something,
however called a limited partnership
that has a two kinds of partners,
the general partner
and the limited partner or and
usually many limited partners. Uh,
and so the general partner
takes on the liability. Uh,
the limited partners,
uh, don't have liability.
So typically real estate is held in a
limited partnership. It's limited because,
uh, well they want to put it in a
limited partnership because they don't,
it's not easy to sell other people on
joining the partnership if they could get
unlimited liability for doing so.
So there is a general partner who
takes on the liability and the, uh,
the limited partners who are many are,
uh,
are the participants who
do not share the liability.
So the general partner is typically the
organizer of the, of the partnership.
Someone who buys a 50 story
building downtown and then,
uh,
well ranges Tobiah and gets partners,
limited partners to join in financing it.
And so that's the arrangement.
You have a general partner and
limited partners, uh, and um,
you don't hear about,
uh,
dpps I'm telling you something that
you probably haven't heard a lot about.
Uh, this is not commonly
advertised or described,
just like hedge funds are not commonly
advertised in describe because it is
thought that dpps are suitable only for
wealthy and sophisticated investors.
They're complicated.
Uh,
so the general rule has been that,
um,
only accredited investors, uh,
should participate in them.
And so, uh, accredited,
I mentioned this before in the u
s and in other countries as well,
there are estimate similar thing we define
an accredited investor is someone who
can participate in a DPP or
other sophisticated programs.
And that definition
is in regulation d,
which defines a,
an accredited investor. Uh,
and, uh, for many years now,
uh,
to be qualified as an accredited investor,
you have to have $1 million in wealth
or income in excess of $200,000.
Or if you're married $300,000
for the couple, uh, in, uh,
2000 and I mentioned this before in 2006,
the sec proposed raising the definition
to make it harder to be an accredited
investor, but they haven't
done that yet. Uh, so,
uh, it remains that $1 million
to do it. But nonetheless,
a DPP is don't advertise. So you see
mutual fund advertisements everywhere.
You don't see advertisements
for participation in
commercial real estate like
this because, uh, the government would
be on their backs if they did it.
Since it's available only
to accredited investors,
you can't be advertising because
everyone would see it. Uh, so, um,
that, uh, that's why, uh,
the financing of a lot of this real
estate is something of a mystery could
because they can't talk
openly about it. Uh, sorry.
Uh, these DPP is go back a long time. Uh,
but there began to be complaints about
though because people said, well,
why is it that because I'm
not an accredited investor,
I can't get into real estate like these
other people do. Why is it, you know,
why isn't there something
offered to me that's like a,
a DPP that's available to everyone?
Or another way of putting it,
the government is effectively saying
that unaccredited investors are free to
invest in corporations that invest in
real estate and they're subject to the
corporate profits tax.
All right?
Wealthy people have the choice of
getting around the corporate profits tax.
So in a sense the tax
structure was regressive.
It was saying we're going to have lower
taxes on rich people then on ordinary
people. And that didn't seem fair at
all. So there was a complaint, uh,
aired about how about DPPS,
uh,
in the late 1950s, uh, and people said,
let's change it.
Let's make it so that everybody
can have something like a DPP.
So Congress finally acted,
um,
and uh,
it was in the year 1960 that Congress
defined a new investment vehicle called a
real estate
investment trust.
And this is for everyone.
Uh,
real estate investment trust
is for smaller investors,
although wealthy big investors
can invest in it also. Uh,
and so, um, the, um,
they had to make a distinction.
So these are called routes. Um,
r E.
I t a real estate investment trust
congress had to make a distinction between
these and corporations.
And it's kind of a subtle distinction
because there's a lot of corporations that
own real estate. Like for example,
Walmart. All right, Walmart,
why they pay corporate profits tax?
So after ninth,
I don't know if Walmart was it
around in 1960, I don't know. Uh,
let's say it was all Walmart
after the 1960 [inaudible],
uh, act of Congress, it would say, hey,
we're a real estate investment trusts.
We are real estate. All
these, how these stores,
but that's not what the
intent of this bill was.
They wanted to reach to be companies
that just own real estate. Uh,
and Walmart is primarily a retailer.
Uh,
okay.
So they specified
that 75% of assets must be real estate
and 75%
of income,
the real estate income. So that would, uh,
that would be ruling out Walmart.
Um,
uh,
and 95% of income must be paid out.
They can't read it.
Pain earnings
that limits
further. They're supposed to be
like a pass through a vehicle. They,
they're owning real estate on your behalf,
so they shouldn't be
retaining earnings. Uh, uh,
also they had to be longterm holders.
Uh,
it had to be less than 30%
of,
um,
income from sales of properties
for less than four years.
Less than no more than 30% of their
income from sale of properties had to be,
uh, from properties held less than
four years. They didn't want flippers.
They didn't want a company
that that's speculating.
They want it to be a
holder of real estate.
So real estate investment
trusts became very important.
Uh, and uh, actually in three waves,
the first wave of rate,
um,
growth occurred in right after
Congress passed the 1960 bill.
So, uh, the, the first
wave was in the 1960s.
At that time,
Congress had limit or governments,
state governments had limits
on the interest that, uh,
savings banks could pay
people on their accounts.
So a lot of people switched
from savings accounts.
Uh, two, two, uh, reads,
and that's called disintermediation.
Uh, an intermediary is a bank. Uh,
and so when they pull out of banks,
they were disinter mediating and
going from banks into reads a,
although in some sense it wasn't really
disintermediation because you could say
a rate is a different kind of intermediary
between the individual and the
investment.
The second boom and rates
occurred
after 1986.
The tax reform act of 1986 made DPP
is much less valuable to investors.
And so a lot of wealthy people switched
from dpps to reads before 1986,
the tax law allowed use of DPPS as a tax
loss device and people would invest in
buildings solely for tax purposes because
you could write off the depreciation
on the building.
Uh,
and so people were cynically setting
up dpps as tax shelters only.
And Congress said,
finally,
I think wisely in 1986 that we don't want
to create rules that encourage people
to do a different sort of business
just to evade taxes. So they, they,
they made, uh, uh, they,
they said that losses
depreciation that in 1986,
the tax reform act of 1986 said that
depreciation on structures in dpps can,
uh,
is called a passive loss and can be
used to offset only passive income,
which comes from, uh, uh,
something like another DPP.
And so it eliminated the tax advantage.
So if they didn't have a
particular tax advantage to DPPS,
they went into, um, into rates.
And then the third greet
boom, uh, was in the 1990s.
Uh, and I think that this third rate boom
is different from the others because it
didn't, uh, arise from any
government regulation change.
It arose from, uh, the beginnings
of the, of the housing bubble,
the real estate bubble that we're now in.
So they're just became a lot of enthusiasm
for rates. It's not just a bubble.
It's also that rates began
to be more diversified. They,
they had many different kinds of rates
for different kinds of real estate.
It became a more interesting
and diverse, uh, uh,
asset class.
Uh,
so,
so that's what I wanted to say
about commercial real estate.
So the two principal ways that commercial,
whether it's three ways,
one is commercial real estate is held
by corporations in the line of business,
but after that it would be dpps and reads.
And we have democratized.
Now rates are a rapidly growing
force in, uh, in investing.
And now, uh, we have substantially
democratized real estate holdings.
So it's not exclusively
DPPS, uh, that are holding,
are not primarily,
we have a lot of rates now.
Okay.
So then the next topic I wanted
to talk about, mortgages.
Mortgages are,
uh,
debts secured by property as collateral.
Uh,
so that when you mortgage property,
that means that you offer the
property as collateral for a loan.
And that means that if you
fail to pay on the loan,
the property is taken
by the lender, uh, to,
uh,
satisfy your debts.
It makes it possible for people to
borrow who otherwise couldn't borrow. Uh,
if you,
if you put a property up as collateral,
then the lender knows that they can
get the money back from you. So the,
uh,
the critical thing is
the loan to value ratio
lenders or Ltv,
a mortgage lender doesn't want to lend
more than the property is worth because
that would be a loan to
value ratio of over one. Uh,
because then if you fail to pay
on the mortgage, pay off the debt,
the lender can seize the
property and sell it.
But if the loan devalue ratio is,
is greater than one,
they won't be able to get all the
money back. Right. Um, moreover,
whenever they seize the
property and try to sell it,
it usually loses value anyway
in the process. So for example,
if there's a homeowner who have you
lent money to and have homeowner is
defaulting on the mortgage, the
homeowner might wreck the house, uh,
that happens all the time. Or they
might steal things from it. Who knows?
They're angry and they're
living in this house,
and then they can stall you for a year.
You're trying to sell the,
how they hire lawyers and sue you,
and you've got to hire lawyers.
So there's a lot of costs.
So you want to have a loan devalue ratio,
which is sufficiently low
that you the collateral,
we'll cover the value of the loan.
Okay.
Now the history of
mortgages, uh, is that, uh,
they have generally over time,
gotten more easy on
loan to value ratio and,
uh,
also on maturity.
The maturity of a mortgage is
the date when it's paid off.
Okay? So if we go back to the 1920s, okay,
uh,
and I compare that with now 1920s,
the typical mortgage had in
loan to value ratio of 60%.
Uh,
and a maturity
of five years, often
even less than that. Uh,
and so, um, they also had,
they were back then in the 20s,
they were called balloon payment.
What that means is,
uh,
you would borrow $5,000 to buy a house,
and in five years and
every year along the way,
you'd be paying interest on your mortgage.
And then in five years you had
to come up with $5,000. Okay.
So it was interest, interest, interest
until the end. And then it was the 5,000.
Of course,
five years is too short because most
people live in a house for more than five
years. But the assumption was,
well, when five years comes up,
you refinance the mortgage,
you get a new one.
The banks weren't willing to lend more
than five years because they didn't trust
you. They thought things
would change and whatever. Um,
after 1929 real estate prices fell
dramatically and people became unemployed,
the unemployment rate in the
United States rose to 25%.
Lots of people could not refi,
refinance their mortgages
because they were unemployed.
And you go to a bank and say,
I want a bow to refinance my mortgage,
which is due now they're asking me
to pay $5,000. I don't have $5,000.
But the bank would say,
hey, you're unemployed.
We can't give you a mortgage anyway.
Your loan to value ratio is getting pretty
precarious because your house is now
down 30% in value.
You're a loan devalue ratio.
If we are to give you a $5,000 would be
something like 90% and they would say,
no way are we going to do that.
Our rule says we can't lend
on a LTV of higher than 60%.
So people would be turned down for the
refinancing of their mortgage and what
happened? They would lose the house. Uh,
and so that happened in
huge numbers in the 1930s.
The 1930s was the, uh,
the biggest housing crisis
in US history.
So,
uh,
you see what the problem was?
The mortgages were too short, uh,
the loan to value ratio, well,
it's not so much the loan.
It was the maturity was short a and the
balloon payment at the end that they
change. So, uh, in 1933
MMM.
Under the Roosevelt Administration,
uh,
Congress created something called
the home owners I mentioning this it,
it's actually relevant to right now,
homeowners loan corporation.
Okay.
R H, O, l, z.
That was financed by the u s congress
and it started offering indirectly,
but I started offering mortgages to all
these people who couldn't refinance.
Okay. It did it through
banks. They, they, they,
they gave the money to banks to make
loans to people who were in trouble. Uh,
and they, they created a very important
change. They said five years is too short.
It's gotta be longer.
They said 15 years. Okay.
And get rid of this balloon payment
thing at the end. That was a dumb idea.
People can't pay that if
they're in any trouble.
They can't come up with the whole
value of the, of the loan all at once.
And so they made it,
they demanded that the
mortgage is be self amortizing.
This is what came in in 33.
It was a very important
change in mortgage finance.
Self Amortizing means that you're not
just paying the interest every year or
every month,
you're paying interest plus principle
so that when the mortgage ends,
you're just clear and free.
You don't have to pay anything.
Nothing comes at the end. And, and so the,
the HLLC said that's a lot more sensible.
And so they demanded that that'd be done.
And of course,
banks would be reluctant
to do it by themselves,
but when the government is coming with
a checkbook to write the money so that
they can make the Lavar grudge
and guarantees it, the hosc said,
don't worry if they don't
pay, we'll look. We'll, okay.
So, uh, the banks said,
of course we'll do that.
And that created a major
change in mortgage lending.
It's especially relevant because,
I don't know if you saw,
maybe you did in the New York
Times yesterday. Alan blinder,
who is a former vice chairman of the
Federal Reserve Board under Greenspan,
is now a professor at Princeton,
had an article saying,
we need to bring back the
HLLC now. Uh, and in fact,
our own Senator Christopher Dodd has a
bill in Congress right now to bring back
the hosc basically. Uh, he wants
it. He has a new name for it. Uh,
uh, I think it's called Home
Equity Protection Corporation.
The almost the same idea.
So ideas that were common that were new
in the 1930s are being brought back,
but we don't have to make the change.
We're well in a sense.
The other thing that happened is in 1934,
uh,
Congress set up the federal
housing administration,
Fha and the Fha is specifically aimed at,
at guaranteeing loans,
mortgages for low income people.
And it was a vision that Roosevelt had
to bring more and more people into owning
homes in this country.
The FHA went further
than the HLC and they,
they demanded that mortgages be 20 years
also self amortizing. Okay. So this was,
maybe it's more of a paternalistic
role of government that came in.
Then the government said that the private
sector with these kinds of mortgages
is not doing things right.
It's not planning for our
future in the right way. Uh,
and so they made the switch.
It was really the government that made
the switch from five year mortgages to
the longterm mortgages. Now
as today, the Standard Mormon,
which would you would probably get when
you buy your first house is not 15 or
20. It's 30 years. Well
they just kept going up.
The 30 year mortgage came
in in the early 1950s,
but it seems to have gotten stuck
at 30 years. That's because, well,
when you buy your first house,
you might be 25 30 years
brings you to age 55.
That's close enough to retirement.
I guess most people think
30 years is long enough.
But that's the way
mortgages go ever since.
But we have to,
what we've seen recently,
we had more government intervention back
then in the mortgage industry since the
1990s.
We've seen a proliferation of
new kinds of mortgages that uh,
especially are offered to low
income people buy certain lenders.
Uh, so, um,
okay.
We've had a growth in popularity of arms,
which are adjustable rate mortgages,
adjustable rate mortgages have a long
term. They might last for 30 years,
but the interest rate is not fixed
for the whole 30 years. So, uh,
a typical arm is two and 28,
which means that it has a low
teaser rate for two years.
A teaser
when they call it a and then rates that
go up after two years and then tied to
some other benchmark rate of interest,
like the treasury bill rate. Uh,
and so, uh, the, the
problem is then that, uh,
these were sold to low income people in
many cases who didn't understand what
they were getting and that the, after two
years, the interest rate would reset up.
Uh,
so we would see resets after two
years to a much higher level.
And some of these people will discover
that they can't afford them. Uh, and so
we need, uh, and there's a lot of
talk in Congress right now. Uh,
we need to,
uh,
think about new regulations that protect
individuals much like the regulations
that the h o l c, uh, and the Fha made.
But we have to do it again because
the mortgage institutions, uh,
have deteriorated somewhat. There's a lot
of anger about it. I know on Thursday,
um, Angelo Mozilo who is
a head of countrywide,
which is one of the biggest mortgage
lenders to low income people,
it made a lot of subprime loans is being
called before a house committee, uh,
to testify. Uh, I want to
try to watch it faster,
but it's going to be interesting because
there's a lot of anger about what's
happened similar to the anger
that we saw in the 1930s,
uh,
Ho hos see is no longer with us.
It was actually set up as
a temporary camp, uh, uh,
corporation by the
government. But, uh, it's, uh,
the Fha is still with us and you know,
we just had an Fha modernization act.
Congress is starting to propel
that forward, so it'll be
a bigger part of our, uh,
I wanted to say it a little bit
about the math of, um, of, uh,
mortgages. The, uh, uh,
typical the convention.
I'm going to talk about the
conventional 30 year mortgage,
which has been a standard,
uh, in the United States, uh,
ever since the early 1950s.
Uh,
it's not a standard in most countries.
Actually.
I think it was partly the
new deal legislation that
made it very strong in the
United States. In Canada. Uh,
the mortgages tend to be shorter term.
It's something like
what we had in the 30s,
although they have other institutions
that protect home buyers,
so they don't see, they
don't see the, uh, the, um,
the turmoil that we saw in the 1930s.
But a typical home,
um, uh, probably about it
30 year
mark. This is what most people
get today. Uh, and that's,
except for subprime,
subprime borrowers seem to be the ones
who are being really hit with new,
new ideas.
But if most people who are good Bowers,
who know what they're doing,
what these,
they want a conventional 30 year mortgage
because it will fix a mortgage payment
for the rest of the 30 years.
And you have nothing to worry about.
If you can afford the mortgage
payment, uh, then, uh,
then you're, you're all set. You don't,
you just pay it every month and then
you just start paying at the end of 30
years. So, uh, if they quote
the rate on the mortgage,
uh, call that are, uh,
traditionally you would
be paid paying monthly.
So if you do it in monthly terms,
your interest rate is our over 12,
because there's 12 months in a year.
Okay.
How did they figure out what the
mortgage payment is? Uh, well,
the, the mortgage balance, uh,
mortgage
balance
is equal to the mortgage payment
times.
And now we just use the annuity
formula, which is the formula that, uh,
we've learned. Uh, again, I think
we've seen it again and again,
one all over the interest rate because
are over 12 times one minus one over
one plus r over 12 to the 12
t power where t is the term,
uh,
in years of the mortgage.
Okay.
Uh,
[inaudible], uh, I should
maybe make this the same
to get my brackets right. All right.
This is just the annuity formula.
Remember, uh, what,
what this equation merely says is that
the present value of your remaining
payments is always equal to
the mortgage balance. Uh,
and so this is how they actually
compute the payments. Because,
uh, you can take, if you want, if someone
is borrowing, let's bring it up to today,
they're borrowing $200,000.
The median price of a home today is
just over 200,000 in the u s so if,
if it's an 80% mortgage,
you would be borrowing a 160,000.
Okay?
So you'd have a 160 k here.
Uh,
and you know what this is whatever
the mortgage rate is coated,
you substituted into this formula and you
find out what the square bracket thing
is.
And then to get the monthly payment,
you take the square bracket and
thing and you divide by, uh,
the mortgage balance. And
that's the monthly payment.
That's how it's calculated.
Um, so one peculiar property
of this, incidentally,
at every point of time this thing holds,
this is time to maturity.
This is, this is, um,
years to go.
All right? And so 12 t would be the
number of months to go before it ends.
So at every point of time your mortgage
balance is equal to your mortgage
payment times that square bracket of
thing where t is the amount of time you
have left. So I suppose, um, you are uh,
moving after five years,
he took out a 30 year mortgage and
you're moving after five years.
When you first bought the house,
they told you what the mortgage payment
was and they're fixing that forever and
ever for 30 years. So when you get, when
you sell the house, what do they do?
They go back to this formula.
If you sold it after five years,
then there's 25 years left.
So 25 times 12 is a number of months left.
They plugged that into this formula.
The mortgage payment is,
this was decided when you took out
the mortgage. So that never changes.
They then figure out what your
mortgage balance is. Okay.
And then the deal is that when
you sell the house, they subtract,
you've got to pay this, they subtract
this from the purchase price of the house,
and then you've got the cash
to go and buy another house.
But that's how it works.
Okay.
It's very important to understand
that the mortgage balance is, um,
is recomputed according to
this formula every month.
And they will send you a statement showing
how your mortgage balance is falling.
Peculiar property of this is that the
mortgage balance fall slowly at first and
then it gradually picks up.
It's just a property of this formula.
When you first buy a house, most of
your payment is going to interest, uh,
your payment. Your mortgage
payment is constant through time,
but the fraction of it that goes to paying
off principal versus interest changes
through time and it just changes
as dictated by this formula.
And that's because at the end,
if suppose you're one month or two months
away from the payoff of the mortgage,
you don't have any balance left.
And so the interest that you're paying
is hardly any balance left is very low.
And so your payment is paying
off principle. Uh, mostly,
whereas at the beginning
you're the, uh, the, the,
the mortgage balance is dropping only
very slowly because you've got a lot of
interest to pay and your mortgage
payment is constant. So, uh,
that's funny. Property of, of
conventional mortgages that the,
the mortgage balance declines
very slowly at fast first,
and then it falls rapidly
when it comes to maturity.
Okay.
Um,
okay. So I wanted to, um,
but just mentioned,
I wanted to mention a couple of other
institutions that are very important in
real estate and that is,
uh, fanny and Freddy, uh,
in 1938 as part of the new deal,
uh,
I'll just write Fannie Mae,
1938 under the Roosevelt administration
in order to further work on the problem
and housing,
which was still troubling them,
they created a government
institution called federal,
National Mortgage
Corporation. Uh, and, uh,
people on Wall Street found that
difficult to say Federal National Mortgage
Corporation. So they nicknamed at Fannie
Mae, uh, it sounds like a woman's name.
Uh, and so the idea was
that they would help, uh,
advanced the mortgage market by
buying up mortgages from our mortgage
originators,
uh,
and therefore allowing them
to make more mortgages. Okay.
So you would buy mortgages
from originators.
What does an originator and originator
is a company that lends money to hustled.
Okay. So they, they raised money and
then they landed artists, mortgages,
the households,
and then they deal with the households
by having a local office and, uh,
telling people, uh,
what their balances and,
and calling them up if they're not
paying. And that sort of thing. Uh,
where they were,
that's a servicer is someone who might
make a distinction between originator and
service or the originator is
the one who makes the loan.
The servicer is someone who
manages the paying of the loan.
And Congress thought that these people
could be given more money to operate if
they, if someone would buy
the mortgages from them.
So Fannie Mae started doing that in 1938.
Uh,
and then the government
created a second such, uh,
uh, institution called, and they gave
it a boy's name, some of the nickname,
a boy's name, uh, with Freddie Mac. Uh,
so the government created competitors,
uh,
and it privatized them so that both
Fannie and Freddie became what are called
GSEs.
Uh,
these are government
sponsored enterprises.
Technically,
Fannie and Freddie are private companies.
They're traded stocks.
You can buy shares in Fannie and Freddie.
They're not part of the government,
but they were created by the
government and they are massive,
uh,
supporters of the housing market.
So the general market assumes, and also
the government still regulates them.
Uh,
it tells how there's a conforming loan
limit that is a limit on how much fanny
and Freddy, uh, how big a mortgage
they can make to one homeowner.
And it was just part of the new President
Bush has planned to increase the
conforming loan limits on Fannie and
Freddie to allow them to lend at a higher
price. So you can see the government
is still involved in them while they're
technically private companies.
Now there are still thought to
be related to the u s government.
And so people are willing to lend to
these organizations at low interest rates
because they think there's an
implicit government guarantee.
There are critics of Fannie and Freddie
who say the government guarantee it
doesn't sound right because why is the
government guaranteeing a private company?
On the other hand, the government
says it's not guaranteeing them,
but then nobody believes the government
when they say, because people say,
surely the u s government is not going
to allow Fannie and Freddie to fail.
This is very important.
Suddenly now with the housing crisis,
and if you just saw the news yesterday,
Fannie Mae is predicting where they are
predicting that Fannie Mae is going to
make huge losses, uh, in their
latest earnings statement.
Uh, and so, uh, it, it's still, they
can make losses for a long time, uh,
before they're in trouble.
So presumably there won't be a problem,
but in principle there could be.
And so that's the kind of
issue that we have now. Um,
okay.
I want her to talk about the current boom,
and I have so much to say
about this. Uh, but, uh,
uh,
let me see if I can.
MMM.
So,
um,
this is a plot that I created for
the second edition of my book,
uh,
irrational exuberance that shows the
real estate market and the United States
since 1890.
Uh,
and what is really significant.
I created this plot,
uh, just a couple of
years ago in 2005. Uh,
and uh, to my surprise,
nobody had it before,
created a 100 year long home price index,
which seems surprising to me because a,
the long history of home prices
seems like a relevant fact. Uh,
we want to know what markets do.
A lot of people have the impression
that home prices only go up, uh,
and that there are a wonderful investment.
So I thought we should try to find
out what home prices have done.
So I constructed a series of
home price that's the red line.
And the red line is,
um,
you can see how it's a
move through history.
It has suddenly shot up in the,
uh,
in the latest year is this is
since the late 1990s. So this, um,
this behavior recently,
uh,
I think confirms that we are living
in a very unusual time in the housing
market. Uh, and it's going
to put a lot of stress on us.
The only other time we've seen a boom,
like this was right after World War II,
and that's this shown by this line
here. Uh, but that wasn't as big.
So after World War II,
uh,
there were two things that
I think contributed to the
huge housing boom at that
time.
One of them was that the US government
had shut down the construction industry
during the war. Uh, and so, uh,
they didn't build any houses
for close to five years.
So obviously we had a shortage of housing.
The other thing was the soldiers came
back from World War II and they wanted
families. They started something that you
may have heard of called the baby boom.
Uh, and so the birth rate shot way up, uh,
and so everyone wanted a home with one
bedroom wasn't good enough anymore.
They wanted, you don't want the baby
in the same room with you, right?
You want to have two bedrooms, um, you
might even want two bathrooms. So, uh,
uh, the demand for
housing went up, but the,
but the current boom is different because
there was nothing like that happening.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
it's strange. Uh, the question
is what caused the current boom.
I have some other data has shown here.
The Green Line is the building costs.
Uh,
and uh, you can see that building
costs since 1890 in realtor,
everything is corrected for inflation.
Building costs have gone up a little
bit since 1890, but not a whole lot.
And in fact,
for the last step,
this is the engineering news
record building costs index.
It's an index used by people in the
construction industry since around 1980.
The building costs have been falling.
Uh,
that I think is partly because the biggest
single component of building costs is
labor. And, uh, as you know,
income inequality is getting worse.
Uh, low income wages are not
going up. Uh, and so, uh,
that component of housing has
been declining in real terms.
The other components are not doing much.
Uh, so, uh,
the other thing I have down is population
or the population of the u s has been
pretty steady, right? That pink line,
it looks awfully steady
and I have interest rates.
Now are a lot of people
talk about interest rates.
I was just reading Alan Greenspan's
new book, the age of turbulence,
and if you saw this,
it came out last year and he said
he didn't think there was a bubble.
I don't know how he can think, not think
there was above him. He didn't see it.
Uh, and is honest. He's, he said
maybe froth in the real estate market,
but not a bubble. Uh, but
anyway, I was reading, well,
why didn't you think there's
a bubble? And he said, well,
part of the reason is interest rates were
coming down and if interest rates are
coming down, as you can see, they are,
that means the rate of discount is going
down and the present value formula.
So ash asset prices should go up.
MMM.
I guess that's plaza.
It doesn't match up very well though,
because interest rates have been
going down since 1980 and the,
and the room is very sudden.
So it seems to me that Greenspan
should have seen this bubble coming.
Uh, uh, so
what causes that? That's the, um, uh,
I wanted to show you one city that,
that I actually do it.
There's a short comparison
between a couple of cities, uh,
Los Angeles and Milwaukee.
Who is there anyone here from Los Angeles?
How are we got a good number.
What about Milwaukee?
Nobody from Milwaukee.
Um,
I might be insulting Milwaukeeans
when I talk about the,
not really no walkie.
Is there someone up there?
Yeah. Huh. Um, so,
uh, Milwaukeeans are, um, uh,
much more stable than this is actually
prays for loss ever for Milwaukee.
It's not, not the, um,
Milwaukee ends are much more stable than
Angelenos I guess you call them, right?
Los Angeles resident.
Look what the housing,
the Blue Line shows what home prices in
real terms have done two in Los Angeles,
uh, uh, over the last 30 years. When
you compare Norwalk, you look at that.
Isn't that amazing? Milwaukee has been
extremely steady over this period.
Uh, so one theory is that, well,
it's because people say I'm
going back to Los Angeles.
The problem with Los Angeles is that
they've had a unsteady employment and
unemployment. Uh, if, if they,
if the economy is sagging,
then the Los Angeles housing
prices will respond. Well.
You can see the pink line shows
the employment in Los Angeles. Uh,
and indeed it did move
around corresponding to the
booms and busts in the Los
Angeles market,
but not so dramatically.
And if you look at Milwaukee,
the unemployment,
the employment figures don't look that
much different than Los Angeles. Uh,
what's different?
There's something about Los Angeles
that's different from Milwaukee,
and that is that in Los Angeles there's
just a history of volatile markets.
Uh, and, um, I wanted to try and
figure out why, what, you know,
Milwaukee, the reason we picked
these two, these two cities,
we asked realtors or Carl
Case is my colleague, he
teaches at Wellesley College.
Uh, it, back in 1988 when
we started this study,
we asked realtors around the country,
what is the hottest market in the
United States? Uh, and they say, oh,
that's Los Angeles. Uh, or maybe
Anaheim, which is where it right outside.
Um, and then we say, what's the, the
dentist market and United States,
there wasn't as much agreement on that,
but one of the names
suggested was Milwaukee.
Nothing has ever happened there
in terms of real estate. Uh,
now I think that ultimately, uh,
you know, interestingly enough,
Los Angeles had a real estate
boom and bust in the 1880s.
Uh, that's hard to believe. There was a
huge boom in real estate prices in La,
in it peaked in 1886 and then a crash.
Now you might think, uh,
that's a long time ago. 1886.
Isn't that when the cowboys and Indians
were out there in the old west and the
covered wagons and uh, well that's
right. But there was a real estate boom,
uh, in Los Angeles. And so I
went back and studied this. Boom.
It rather extensively, uh, by, uh,
there's one book written about,
there's also the La Times,
which you can get now online
with no problem from the pier.
You can read every day's newspaper.
And it turns out I was talking
about what in La and the 1880s,
they're a view arose that Los Angeles
was just the most wonderful place on
earth.
The climate out there is beautiful,
especially feel that on a
winter's day like today,
you might wish you were in some of
you, you might wish you were there. Uh,
but it wasn't just California because
California was a huge state, right,
with all kinds of,
but mostly empty land.
People somehow got the idea that Los
Angeles is just this wonderful city and so
they started built bidding up real estate
prices. You can explain that to me.
Some of it from Los Angeles.
Uh,
it turned out to be kind of wrong because
in the 1880s they started building so
many houses in response to the demand
that there was eventually a crash.
But somehow people get
this idea at some time.
So we compared loss and we couldn't
go back in a time machine and do
questionnaires, surveys, and the
1880s but we could do it in the 1980s.
So a case,
and I did identical questionnaire
is in Los Angeles and Milwaukee.
Uh, and these are median
price expectations in 1988
when there was a boom in
California,
but of course not in Milwaukee,
the average person in Los Angeles thought
home prices would go up 10% a year for
the next 10 years. That's
the median, I'm sorry. Uh,
10% a year is a pretty fast appreciation
and if it goes on for 10 years,
that means that the oil
double in seven years.
So it'd be going up like
two and a half fold. Um,
that was quite an a nice expectation.
If you compare that with Milwaukee,
they thought only 4%,
which is about the inflation rate.
So there was something different
between Los Angeles and Milwaukee.
The Los Angeles people had
extravagantly high expectations.
We saw it again in 2003,
uh,
when people in Los Angeles expected
8% appreciation every year,
uh, it's coming down now in 2006
they're gradually coming down as the,
as the boom unwind.
But you notice no walkie is going up.
I think what's happening is that we're
becoming more national and Milwaukeeans
are starting to think more like Angelenos,
uh,
that it's one boom. And so they start
to expect it to happen in Milwaukee.
So Las Angeles in Milwaukee, we're
tied in 2006 where their expectations,
this is the boom.
Uh,
people had great fear of being
left out of the real estate market.
I think the boom was driven by fear.
So in 1988,
we asked people in Los Angeles, uh,
are you worried? Unless I buy now,
I won't be able to afford
a house in the future.
We had 80% agreement
with that in Los Angeles.
So people were really worried.
Uh,
in Milwaukee it was only 27%.
you kind of wonder how can it be
that the people had such different,
depending on which city they lived in.
Well,
I can kind of explain it that there's
a couple of factors. One is in 1988,
home prices were rising rapidly in
Los Angeles, not so in Milwaukee.
So people were just
extrapolating the price increase.
But the other thing is that Los Angeles
just has this sense of its own glamor
and excitement that, uh, you know,
it is the home of movie stars. What,
what city is more glamorous, or Beverly
Hills is part of Los Angeles, right?
And it's the most expensive
city in the u s uh,
so this sense,
this glamour thinking along with price
increases because the Los Angeles to
boom, so it's the boom. He asked us city,
we ask people whether they had a
perception of excitement, uh, directly.
And in Los Angeles in 1988,
54% said yes.
Whereas in Milwaukee,
only 21% said yes. Um, but as you know,
as the years go by,
you notice that Milwaukee is starting to
look more and more like Los Angeles. Uh,
uh,
Alan Greenspan in his book says that he
thinks housing markets are all local.
And there is no,
he says this firmly in his book,
there is no national housing
market. Uh, but in fact,
it's becoming more national because
Milwaukeeans no longer think that they are
some kind of outpost. It's unrelated to
the excitement of a glamorous cities.
They see it happening
at home as well. So, um,
now I wanted to compare it
with another question that, uh,
people have this simple idea
that there's a best investment.
This is about the stock market,
but I asked a number of, uh, uh,
this I've been doing since 1996.
Do you agree with the following statement?
The stock market is the best investment
for longterm holders who can just buy
and hold through the ups
and downs of the market. Uh,
I only started asking this in 1996 when
the stock market boom was well underway,
but already 69% of my respondents
who were high income investors,
uh, strongly agreed. That percent
grew to the peak of the market.
In 1,999, after the peak
in 2000, it began to fall.
So we see what happens is that when the
markets, people are chasing past returns,
when the stock market is going up,
they think that they increasingly think
that the stock market is just the best
investment until when it starts falling,
then they start retracting from that.
Uh, or I didn't have what
happened? I lost it. Uh, the, um,
what is going on here?
Oh,
uh, okay. Where were we? So,
um, uh, we see the same
thing in real estate. Uh,
and the percent who think it's the best
investment is higher in Los Angeles then
in Milwaukee.
And since the peak of the bubble in 2003,
it's been declining in Los Angeles,
but surprisingly rising in Milwaukee.
Uh, and so they've almost come, well,
they pretty much converged in 2006.
So the lesson is that I think that we
have a glamorous city phenomenon that
excitement about real estate prices,
uh, centered in places like Los Angeles,
but it's spreading and becoming more
and more of a national phenomenon.
And that's the bubble.
Uh, part of this is the,
uh, uh, it's not loan to value ratio.
This is the ratio of mortgage debt to
personal consumption expenditure. Uh,
over the boom period,
we've been seeing a gradual uptrend just
as loan to value ratios were only 60%
in the 1920s. Now they're
up to 90% of our 100%. Um,
we were much more willing
to take risks on mortgages.
People are also borrowing much more.
So you can see that in the early 1950s,
mortgage debt was only something like 25%
of a personal consumption expenditure,
but now it's up to about 100%.
So we're much more expansive in
mortgage financing. And we were,
I put this chart out to just show the
international aspect of home prices. Uh,
they're here.
The Blue Line is the case Shiller
home price index for a Greater Boston.
Uh,
and the red line is the Halifax a
home price index for greater London.
We're talking UK now and
they're both deflated by, uh,
a consumer price index
or in the case of the UK,
the retail price index to
give us a real home price.
Isn't it striking how similar
London and Boston are?
They both had dramatic booms. Uh, the,
the London boom of the late 19 days
is really something. Look at that.
It went up.
Peak suddenly turned around,
came all the way back down.
I don't know what the, uh,
and then it kind of
waffled around in London.
And then it shot up even higher.
And now look what's happened.
This is the latest quarter. It's
starting to fall rapidly. Uh,
so just a couple of months ago,
London seemed to be sorry.
And now suddenly there's
this pessimistic atmos. Well,
cause we don't know what's going
to happen in London. Look how it,
it fell in 2004,
there was this sharp drop and most people
thought that the housing boom was over.
But then it went up again.
Uh, and so, uh, to a new peak,
uh,
in 2007
we have an international crisis.
This is another couple of countries.
I managed to find a price indexes for
Norway and Netherlands going back to 1890.
And compared that with the u s we're
seeing a similar pattern in all three of
these countries.
These are the only countries that I've
been able to find that have high quality,
uh, repeat sales price index
is going back a hundred years.
You can see that in all these countries,
real estate prices didn't show
much trend until recently.
And now they all have real estate booms.
So we have an international
real estate book. Why is that?
Why would we have an international boom?
Uh, I talked about this in the book.
You have irrational exuberance,
uh,
and I let you read that and
that, uh, summarize it here.
But a part of the reason I think is
globalization is creating a global culture
and the excitement and enthusiasm that
we once saw in isolated cities like Los
Angeles, uh, are spreading out and they're
seeing more and more around the world.
And it's tied in with our
sense of rapid economic growth.
We're living in an era of
excited economic optimism.
And so it's feeding into home prices,
uh,
in the U S in Europe, in China, in Korea,
in India, in South Africa, uh, uh,
Australia and New Zealand. Lots and lots
of places have seen home price boom.
And I think it's,
it's the,
it's not anything unique to any
one country that explains it. It's,
it's the psychology.
I think this is a residential investment
in the United States as a fraction of
GDP. A, and I have it
shown with, um, the, uh,
uh,
the vertical lines on this
chart are recession's indicate
recession's a and this
shows, okay, this is from 1948 to 2007.
And every recession that we've had
since 1948 is shown. For example,
we had a recession that started here.
Uh,
I believe that was 48
and then it ended in 49.
And then we had another recession
that began in 1953. That's that line.
And it ended in 54. Uh, and so on.
The most recent recession we've had is
a 2001 it began and ended in the same
year. 2001 we may be in a recession.
Now, a lot of people are saying that.
So I,
I would be tempted to draw a new
line here somewhere around here,
maybe December of 2007.
Uh,
but the National Bureau of economic
research who announces recession dates
hasn't announced yet
whether there's a recession.
So we'll probably find out in a few
more months whether we're already in a
recession. I suspect we are. Now,
the interesting thing is the,
the Green Line here is the
expenditure on real estate,
uh, investment. What does that
mean? There's three main components.
One is building new houses,
another one is building new
apartment buildings. That's
commercial instead of, oh,
but it's still adding
to the housing stock.
And the third one is improvements
of existing houses people,
but new additions are, are they redo the
kitchen and bathroom and whatever. Uh,
so we add all that up and
that's residential investment.
You can see that residential investment
as a fraction of GDP has been very
variable through history, uh,
of the United States since,
uh, since World War II.
Uh, and that it has had a strong
relationship with recession's.
Uh, so, um,
you can see what a residential
investment has done recently. Uh,
we had a huge peak in
residential investment, uh,
and the peak was a, a couple
of years ago, uh, I believe,
uh, 2006, uh,
or there abouts,
uh,
and at the level of residential
investment was the highest.
It has been since 1951.
And that's over here.
That's the only time since World War
II that we've had a higher level of
residential investment.
Even 1951 was a very unusual year.
Uh,
I'll tell you why because we were
getting into the Korean War and,
uh, the people remembered
that during World War II,
the u s government shutdown
the housing market.
They said no more new houses to be built.
So everyone thought are in fact,
they were talking about world war three.
There were really scared.
You don't remember how awful it looked
because the US was proposing to invade
Korea and then the Soviet Union and China
were being very angry and we thought
we'd be in some war with communist
China. Ours, some awful war.
People got really scared. Uh, but
one thing they did is they want,
this was the baby boom.
They just got back from World War II.
They didn't want another,
they wanted to live a normal life.
They wanted to have kids, and then this
terrible war was coming. They thought,
uh, and so they, they
rushed and bought houses.
So everyone was scrambling to get a
house before they shut down the housing
market. It turns out that it didn't
turn into world war three. Uh, and,
uh, maybe they did shut down the house.
They must've curtailed it. Uh, but it,
it created that book.
But what's causing this boom here?
It's almost as big as the 1951.
Boom. Well, the answer is, uh,
high prices.
I believe we had this huge bubble in
home prices and it pushed prices up to
extraordinary levels. What
does that do to builders? Well,
builders can sell for a really high price,
and so they start building a lot
of houses. They will do it, uh, as,
as long as the home prices high
relative to their construction costs.
So we've seen a boom in building in the
United States that is at a record level,
uh, except for that one
Korean War, a blip. Uh,
and so I think it's,
it's an APP.
It's a highly abnormal situation
that we've been in. Um,
and uh, but now look how suddenly
in sharply it's correcting downward.
Why is it correcting downward?
Well,
that's because the housing
market is now in decline. And,
and so when the housing
market is in decline,
the ability to sell houses
drops dramatically. So builders,
we're doing extremely well. Until a couple
of years ago, their stock was soaring.
Now all of a sudden they're in crisis.
Uh, and well, it's no surprise.
This is what a housing bubble does.
And I have, I think, uh, maybe,
uh, you can see various side, this is
the growth rate of home prices. Actually,
I should update this. This is
now tip negative. Uh, the peak.
This is the case Shiller 10 city index.
Uh,
housing permits have dropped way off,
uh,
because of course they're not building
homes anyway, this shows a law,
a strong seasonality. And then
a dropoff, uh, since the 2006,
and his, my last slide, uh, the
National Association of Home Builders,
uh, surveys its membership to ask them
what is the traffic of homebuyers,
uh, w what they mean by that is if
you're a builder and you have this,
a place where you show
off your model homes,
how many people are coming by to
look at your model homes today, uh,
as put potential buyers. The Blue
Line is the traffic of home buyers.
You can see that it has
reached the lowest level ever.
It has dropped precipitously and you note
that the pink line, which shows the, uh,
the rate of growth of home prices,
the rate of growth of home prices has
fallen just right along with the traffic
of home buyers. So I think it's
pretty clear what's happening.
People saw the rising home prices,
they thought they would rise forever.
They were flocking in trying to get into
the homeless housing market before it w
it out, priced them, and now suddenly
the word is out. It's falling.
So suddenly they don't want these homes.
So the inventory of
unsold homes has shot up.
Builders can't sell them
and prices are falling.
That's a situation where,
and we'll talk more about this very
interesting situation because it,
it ties in with so many other
aspects of financial markets.